Is beer battered fish halal to consume?
Some scholars say that alcohol is not
nudges and during the cooking process
the alcohol is cooked out of it. But
some say
otherwise regarding the question that
can you have beer battered fish? It is
you cook fish in beer or in alcohol so
that the taste is better and it's cooked
better. So is beer battered fish halal
because alcohol is consumed it
evaporates and alcohol is not nudges
etc. Regarding alcohol is nud or not
there's difference of opinion but surely
you cannot consume alcohol. Allah says
clearly in the Quran in surah maida
chapter 5 verse number
90 oh you
believe most certainly intoxicants and
gambling dedication of stones divition
of
arrows these are Satan's
handute abstain from that you may
prosper so this verse of the Quran is
very clear that alcohol is prohibited
regarding your question that if the
alcohol is evaporated so is it allowed
not allowed yes we know that and there
is a faith also So for example, if you
pour alcohol in a lake, the full lake
water does not become haram because the
alcohol is mixed and once it is mixed in
the lake, the percentage is not there at
all. There is no evidence of color of
the alcohol in the lake. There's no
evidence of order of alcohol in the
lake. There's no evidence of taste. When
you taste the water of the lake, it is
0.1%. So if you pour a bottle of alcohol
in the lake water, the whole lake water
does not become haram. So based on this
we know that if it's diluted and the
color is not there, the taste is not
there, the order is not there, it is
permitted. So gave the fatwa. Yes. But
that does not mean that you can use
alcohol in
cooking. And if you read the fatwa of
shikhami, he has said that yes, if it
evaporates and not there, it is fine.
But that does not mean you can add
alcohol as a cooking medium. It is not
permitted because our prophet is very
clearcut. The prophet said anything
which intoxicates in large quantity is
even probable in a small quantity. So
when you're using alcohol in cooking
purposely it's not permitted. It is
haram. So you cannot add beer or alcohol
for cooking and then say the beer
evaporates. So that's not permitted. We
are talking about alcohol poured in lake
water. That's different. But you cannot
use alcohol for cooking because most of
the time some remains will be there. But
even if it's not there, it is not
correct to use it as a medium for
cooking. It's haram. So beer battered
fish is not permitted and it is not
permitted for you to have it. It's
haram. Hope that answer the question.